excuse me I think we're ready to order
well I'm sorry that's not how things
work in this establishment someone will
come to you yes we're sorry no no
problem what was that what we're was
black Jeff black Jeff yeah black Jeff I
read somewhere that when you date a
biracial guy you're supposed to get the
best of both worlds so there are white
Jeff situations and there are black-jeff
situations and that was definitely a
black-jeff situation oh okay hi folks
I'm so sorry for the wait can I get you
bottled or tap water for the table this
evening how about I borrow your ass and
kick it down the stairs man we've been
waiting half an hour for one of you
to show up I'm so I'm so
sorry I'll get you a bottle of our
finest premium water on the house that's
what I say a bitch what are you doing
what black Jeff that was black Jeff he
was just trying to help us oh so white
white Jeff yes good evening
I'm sorry to bother you - I am the
maitre d here at Chez Henri oh yes what
is it I am so sorry to disturb you both
but our establishment has a certain
dress code and Madame's um decolletage
is inappropriate
oh my god we're we're very sorry we
didn't know there was a dress code we'll
certainly remember for the next time but
they won't be no next time for you
looking at my woman and her day cold
chuckle chuckle ice or whatever you say
bro here okay see it was really a simple
misunderstanding it all started with
that right there who is
disrespecting myself and my girl but we
really love this guy and he gave us
exceptional Asser we're gonna have to
ask you to leave you have to ask me to
leave all you have to ask the black man
to leave huh actually don't have to ask
her so laters want to see ourselves out
and we ain't never coming back again
though we really appreciate your help
that's it oh no siento mucho watch your
ass man
let us reimburse you for that breakage
okay right after I burn this hole
the round everybody inside
of it by which I mean you're going to
get a very negative review on Yelp
[Music]